- [Narrator] For many people
throughout the pandemic
dinner plans usually look like this.
You look up your favorite local restaurant
on an app like Uber Eats or Deliveroo
if you're in the UK, place an order,
track it on the map, grab
the bag from your doorstep
and voilà, dinner delivered.
But sometimes in those bags,
restaurants include notes like these
encouraging customers to order
directly from them next time.
That would mean
they don't have to pay delivery companies
commission fees of up to 35%.
Restaurants around the world
have organized to push delivery services
to lower their fees.
While recognizing these apps
have become very important.
- They are massively crucial
but grudgingly crucial actually (chuckles)
it's hard giving away your
hard-earned cash to a platform,
but yeah they're keeping us afloat.
- [Narrator] While restaurants
have been struggling
with the pandemic, delivery services like
Uber and DoorDash have boomed.
By the end of 2020 food delivery spending
had more than doubled compared to 2019.
But spending at restaurants
was down roughly 5%.
- That will be the legacy of
the pandemic in this sector.
Everyone had to change
their behavior overnight.
- [Narrator] So are delivery apps,
helping restaurants or hurting them?
The food delivery market as we know it
actually started about 20 years ago,
when Grubhub in the US
and Just Eat in Europe,
entered the market.
- The generation one operators,
the roots of this business model
we're working with independent restaurants
and independent restaurants
that had existed for decades
prior to the platform coming along.
I got my Deliveroo bag and my bike
and I'm gonna spend a couple
of hours doing some orders.
- [Narrator] Giles Thorne researches
European internet companies for Jefferies
and to better understand
the food delivery industry
he spent some time
actually making deliveries
for Deliveroo in the UK in 2019 and 2020.
- Everything changed in around 2016, 2017
because the generation
two competition came in
and these were delivery led.
These were platforms like
Deliveroo, like DoorDash,
like Uber Eats that
saw the consumer value,
the utility of an online food delivery app
and that the branded
chains, the big restaurants
not the independent pizza parlor in London
but the McDonald's three doors along
would also benefit from the utility
of this type of platform.
- [Narrator] There are a lot of companies
vying to take control
of the food delivery industry right now.
The global market was projected to be
worth $285 billion in 2020.
Margins are low meaning
despite high demand
delivery companies
mostly operate at a loss.
- The reason why a platform
will not be making money
at this point in time
is essentially because they
are in a competitive market.
♪ Did somebody say Just Eat ♪
They are having to spend
a large amount of money,
primarily through marketing
to get consumers, to download
the app and start using them.
The platform says, right,
I got three other guys in my market
by the of next year I wanna
get two of them to exit.
So I'm gonna spend a
hundred million dollars
buying up every billboard.
And I'm gonna send a
message to the other guys
that they are not gonna get traffic.
And that's the logic.
That's why people don't make money.
- [Narrator] Since the
delivery market's inception
there has been a lot of consolidation.
Just Eat has undergone six
major mergers and acquisitions
in the last five years.
Last year, it was acquired by Takeaway.com
which then acquired
Grubhub for $7.3 billion
in the US Uber Eats acquired Postmates
for 2.65 billion in stock.
(bell ringing)
In December, 2020 DoorDash went public.
By the end of the year
the company was worth
at least $50 billion.
Uber, DoorDash and Grubhub
now control roughly 98%
of the overall US food delivery market
in terms of transactions.
In the United Kingdom, Uber
Eats, Just Eat and Deliveroo
are among the most popular
food delivery apps.
One restaurant working with
delivery services like these
is Tai Kitchen in London.
- We set up the business
just before COVID hit.
We literally were open
a week before the pandemic.
- [Narrator] The owner Richard Poole
has relied on services like
Uber Eats and Deliveroo
to keep the restaurant alive
during various levels of
lockdown since March, 2020.
- Those plans were in the pipeline
when it came to us having, eat and service
and having that extra revenue stream
but obviously that went to part.
So we had to improvise.
- [Narrator] Tai Kitchen
also offers its own service
for in-store collection.
- We had to have our own delivery service
but obviously it's a lot...
The logistical nightmare of
having your own delivery service
it's real.
It's a real challenge.
That's why we outsource it
to Deliveroo and Uber Eats
to deliver our food.
Another thing is Deliveroo and Uber Eats,
they basically own all
the drivers (giggles)
It's very, very hard to find independent.
Well, technically they
are independent, right?
But it's very hard to find
someone who'd come over
to work with you.
Do you know what I mean?
'Cause basically, they own the fleets.
- [Narrator] Uber Eats has
nearly 5 million drivers
and delivery people globally
and DoorDash has over 1 million.
Most apps offer restaurants,
a range of services
from just helping
facilitate online ordering
to actually delivering the food.
If the app handles the delivery
the fees can range from 10
to 35% of the total order.
- The whole balance of
deliveries and take-aways.
But right now it's like 80% deliveries
like the whole 85 from our point of view.
So I think let's say to
improve things would be
more people actually coming to collect.
So you come collect an order
you basically gave the restaurant,
a hundred percent of the revenue.
- [Narrator] These tensions
over commission fees aren't new.
McDonald's franchisees
have complained publicly
that Uber Eats erodes their margins.
While Uber has said it offers
some large restaurant chains
a lower service fee.
In 2019 representatives
from the two companies
said they reached a new deal.
And since the pandemic hit
various regions in the
US including New York, LA
and Philadelphia have
temporarily capped delivery fees
for restaurants at 10 to 15%.
DoorDash has said the commission caps
ultimately restrict restaurant choice.
Precisely when restaurants
need the full range of options
to help their businesses
survive and thrive.
Some restaurants are even
working out of ghosts kitchens
where they cook food exclusively
for delivery services.
- At Uber Eats, drivers have
switched off their hailing apps
this weekend to demand better treatment
from the food delivery service.
- [Narrator] Delivery apps
have also come under pressure
from gig workers, demanding
better employment protections
including better wages and sick pay.
The CEO of Uber
recently called for dialogue
but said its delivery app
allows workers to make money
in a flexible way.
DoorDash Grubhub and Uber Eats
told the Wall Street Journal
they've provided drivers with various PPE.
And Just Eat said it supports
contact free delivery
and has given restaurants
reduced commission fees
throughout the pandemic.
As these companies have become a key part
of many people's lives,
regulators are watching
to see the impact on
competition, consumers,
delivery drivers and restaurants
- It's very hard to see our money go
like that amount go to them
but again, credit where it's due
they are keeping us afloat.
So even with the commission
rates, being that high
if it wasn't for them,
we'd actually have to shut.
(soft music)